Ihr schickt uns immer wieder
Fragen, Kommentare.
Wir freuen uns
über euer Interesse an Philosophie.
Ich nehme
ein paar Kommentare oder Fragen auf,
die ich interessant fand.
Sie bringen mich allerdings
ganz schön ins Grübeln.
Z.B. hier auf YouTube.
Okay, das ist eine harte Nuss.
So gefragt
müsste man wahrscheinlich sagen:
Ökologisch besser wäre es,
wenn man keine Kinder hätte.
Dann gäbe es keinen neuen Menschen,
der Windeln, Kleider,
eine Wohnung braucht,
später evtl. ein Auto fährt
und fliegt.
Aber ökologisch besser
wäre auch viel anderes.
Nicht mehr reisen, nichts Neues
kaufen, auf engerem Raum leben,
nichts mehr streamen,
z.B. mir hier zuhören, usw.
Die Frage, die sich stellt, ist also
eher: Worauf sollten wir verzichten,
um die Folgen des Klimawandels
zu mildern?
Letztlich müssen alle selbst wissen,
wo sie ihren Beitrag leisten.
Es kursieren zwar Zahlen,
die sagen, dass jedes weitere Kind
den eigenen ökologischen Fussabdruck
um ein Vielfaches erhöht.
Und zwar in viel extremerem Ausmass
als wenn man nicht mehr Auto fährt
oder auf Fleisch verzichtet.
Aber unsere Kinder
auf diese Art und Weise
mit anderen CO2-Emissionen
zu verrechnen,
scheint doch ziemlich unmenschlich.
Vielleicht ist ein Kind
auch gerade ein Ansporn,
sich für eine enkeltaugliche Zukunft
einzusetzen,
wie es der Soziologe Harald Welzer
nennt.
Damit will ich natürlich nicht sagen,
Menschen ohne Kinder
hätten kein ökologisches Gewissen.
Das ist echt vermintes Gelände.
Nächster Kommentar.
Ein Zuschauer hat uns geschrieben:
Einsamkeit ist ein grosses Problem.
Und die Corona-Pandemie hat dieses
Gefühl für viele noch verstärkt.
Grossbritannien
hat vor einigen Jahren sogar
ein Ministerium für Einsamkeit
eingerichtet
und das Rote Kreuz
spricht von Einsamkeit
als Epidemie im Verborgenen.
Einsamkeit soll Herz-Kreislauf-
Krankheiten begünstigen,
die Lebenszeit verkürzen,
depressiv machen.
Und Einsamkeit
sei auch politisch ein Problem,
schreibt z.B. der französische
Filmemacher Raphaël Glucksmann
in seinem Buch
"Die Politik sind wir!".
Wenn sich Bürger/-innen
nicht mehr verbunden
und in einer Gemeinschaft aufgehoben
fühlen, werden sie anfälliger
für Nationalismus
oder krude Heimatversprechen.
Wer durch alle Netze fällt,
wirft sich jenen an die Brust,
die versprechen,
die wahre kleine, nationale
Gemeinschaft zu verteidigen.
Die Globalisierung produziert darum
einfach gesagt mehr Einsamkeit
und wenn es böse kommt
auch mehr Nationalismus.
Einsamkeit als Phänomen
ist also allein
aus politischen Gründen gefährlich.
Man kann nur hoffen, dass wir
vielleicht dank Corona wieder lernen,
in kleineren solidarischen
Nachbarprojekten aktiv zu werden
und die lokale Verbundenheit
wieder mehr zu beleben.
Jemand hat noch diese Frage gestellt:
Egoismus
ist ja eigentlich unsympathisch.
Ich habe mich immer gefragt,
warum das Parfüm Egoïste von Chanel
seit seiner Kreation 1990
zu den bestverkauften Herrendüften
gehört.
Offenbar sind Egoisten
doch irgendwie auch attraktiv.
Aber die Frage war ja,
wann Egoismus eigentlich gesund ist.
Ein Egoist schaut auf jeden Fall
auf seine Interessen
und ist deshalb sicher gesünder
als der totale Altruist,
der sich vor lauter Aufopferung
fast kaputtschuftet.
Aber Selbstliebe kann natürlich auch
ins Negative kippen.
Der Philosoph Jean-Jacques Rousseau
traf in seiner Abhandlung
über den Ursprung
und die Grundlagen der Ungleichheit
1755 eine Unterscheidung,
die hier vielleicht weiterhilft.
Und zwar unterscheidet er
zwischen zwei Formen der Selbstliebe:
erstens die amour de soi.
Sie treibt uns dazu an,
gut zu uns selbst zu schauen
bei geringstmöglichem Schaden
für andere.
Im Naturzustand
leben Menschen und Tiere
mit der amour de soi
friedlich und harmonisch zusammen.
Die amour propre
ist die zweite Form der Selbstliebe.
Sie entspringt
im neidischen Vergleich mit anderen.
Weil wir ums Verrotten
die Besten und Ersten sein wollen,
müssen wir ständig
um soziale Anerkennung kämpfen.
Das macht uns krank
und schwächt die ganze Gesellschaft.
Mit Rousseau kann man also sagen:
Egoismus ist gesund,
wenn er Ausdruck der liebevollen
Sorge um sich selbst ist,
und er wird krankhaft,
wenn er nur noch das Resultat
des Gerangels um den besten Platz
ist.
Eine schöne Frage
ist auch diese einer Hundebesitzerin.
Ob ihr Mann recht hat?
Es kommt darauf an,
was man unter Denken versteht.
Wenn man damit meint, dass ein Hund
sich nicht nur instinktiv verhält,
sondern z.B. nach Regeln der Logik
richtige Schlüsse zieht,
hat ihr Mann recht.
Hunde denken nach allem, was wir
über das Hundehirn wissen, nicht so.
Das heisst aber nicht,
dass hinter der Stirn ihres Haustiers
nichts von sich geht.
Das meinte z.B. René Descartes
im 16. Jh.
Für ihn waren Tiere nur eine Art
mechanisch funktionierende Körper.
Oder im Fall eines Hundes
eine Art fellüberzogener Roboter.
Das ist sicher falsch.
Hunde empfinden Freude, sie können
Angst haben und auf Dinge warten,
z.B. wissen, dass man bald Gassi geht
oder bald das Futter kommt.
Was genau im Kopf ihres Hundes
abgeht, werden wir nie wissen.
Aber ganz ehrlich gesagt
weiss diese Frau das ja auch nicht
von ihrem Mann.
Philosophen sprechen
vom Problem des Fremdpsychischen.
Selbst wenn man ganz genau weiss,
welche Neuronen
wann wo wie zusammenspielen -
wie es sich anfühlt,
jemand anderes zu sein,
wie sich z.B. Kopfschmerzen
im Kopf des anderen anfühlen
oder eine Farbe
für eine andere Person aussieht,
können wir nie herausfinden.
Wir können nur versuchen,
uns in andere hineinzufühlen.
Bei einem Hund
ist das evtl. schwieriger
als bei einem anderen Menschen.
Das Problem
bleibt aber ein ähnliches.
Danke jedenfalls
für eure Fragen und Kommentare.
Ich freue mich
auf neue Anregungen von euch.
Und die erwähnten Bücher
findet ihr alle in der Infobox.